ten weeks
after the death of george floyd during
an attempted arrest a few miles from
here
we came here to assess the situation on
the ground
because the riots that left behind block
after block of destruction left people
in their wake
and tonight we're going to bring you the
never told stories of those business
owners
who were abandoned by the politicians
and the police
now much of what you're going to see and
hear tonight is extremely disturbing
and it begs for political change elected
officials what they should be doing the
focus is on
public safety without public safety this
ecosystem that we're in
doesn't work we've been waiting for
respond from our officials
elected officials we have not heard any
word from them
our dream has been shattered the whole
block burned down
i can sense it's not just about you it's
about this it's about
a formerly vibrant uh community
sure overnight almost yeah this was our
version of a baby
just being here now it's
just all the emotion comes back and all
the
all the sadness and anger just kind of
flows back through
now more of these riveting stories of
ruin and hope
later on in the show now as we walk to
east lake street today i kept thinking
about
how so many of the good people there
they just can't get a break
their votes have been taken for granted
by democrats for decades
and then when they needed safety and
leadership most
the political leaders were nowhere to be
found now when the governor finally
mobilized and deployed the national
guard and accepted federal help
it was too late for many of the people
in the neighborhood criminals and
rioters
they were able to flatten livelihoods
and terrorize those
who deserve safety and peace of mind
now here in minneapolis leftists used
the tragic death of mr floyd
to excuse the criminal devastation and
over the past several weeks in
portland officials there they blame the
violence on president trump
and it was just as pathetic federal
presence has very much
inflamed tension it's had the opposite
effect
president trump is making bad trouble we
know what it is
this perverse pandering
to white americans about law and order
trump is continuing to focus on and
perhaps even fuel
the already volatile situation between
law enforcement and protesters
really it's just throwing gasoline on
fire
but now we see that it was all a lie
more chaos occurred over the weekend
days after the federal presence
retreated
mayor ted wheeler should apologize and
then resign
but he won't he did however finally have
to admit
it's not a peaceful protest when you
commit
arson with an accelerant in an attempt
to burn down a building that is occupied
by people
that you have intentionally trapped
inside
you are not demonstrating you are
attempting
to commit murder we anticipate
additional planned attacks on occupied
public buildings
over the next few days i cannot and i
will not
tolerate that now i think chicago's
looters and thugs were obviously
beginning to feel left out of all the
fun and they
went wild last night taking all the
action to downtown to the famed
magnificent mile shopping district
now it was also brazen that they drove
up to luxury stores
then they loaded up on merchandise then
they just sped away in the cars that
they had left idling
in the streets but the police were too
overwhelmed to stop
all of them now let's remember this is
happening
not because of george floyd and it's not
happening because of police brutality of
some
or some altercation earlier in the
afternoon this is happening
because of 50 years of terrible
leadership in these cities
a breakdown in the family lack of father
figures we all know that
and it's culminating in a summer of
annihilation
where you can assault police officers
and get away with it
you can destroy property you can get
away with it
you can steal from stores in broad
daylight
and get away with it you can brutally
beat
innocent bystanders and you'll get away
with it
and of course you can march by the
thousands
with zero social distancing during a
pandemic
and get away with it now for months
officials in the media they've
alternatively celebrated or
tolerated all of this while hassling the
rest of us
for wanting our kids to go to school or
or to want to have college football
or to have an outdoor picnic which is
what by the way
mayor lori lightfoot was focused on just
hours before the chaos in downtown
it's called a pandemic people she
tweeted well this
reckless behavior on montrose beach is
what will cause us to shut down
the parks and lakefront reckless
behavior
what's reckless is your leadership
along with the leadership of so many of
your democrat colleagues across the
nation
she's hassling tax paying citizens who
are out enjoying the sunshine
and meanwhile she's presided over
a horrific july homicides up 139
compared to last year at least 107
people
murdered and 573 shot
including 58 miners now as that was
happening
just like wheeler and portland mayor
lightfoot was busy blaming president
trump for her city's problems
the trump administration obviously
thinks that they will score some
political points
by trying to demonize and and make
democratic mayors particularly women
mayors and make us look bad because
that'll score points
with their base good luck the mayors are
getting it done
and we are going to get the job done to
protect residents of the city
whether or not the president ever steps
up or not
they're getting it done all right yeah
if your version of getting it done
is what we're being been seeing for the
last several weeks
oh by the way and caving to the teachers
unions did you check that all out over
the weekend
they're shutting down schools there for
in-person learning
it's all going to be online there that's
going to be great for the kids it's
another chicago disaster
but the message is clear no matter how
rich and successful a city is or a
neighborhood in a city is
it can't be saved from poor democrat
leadership
they'll try to defund the police and
then embolden criminals
they'll cry racism to avoid any
accountability for their own failures
and then when it comes time to clean up
the mess that everything's been left
behind
well they're nowhere to be found after
the dust settles
they'll still expect minorities those
hurt most by their god-awful policies
to vote for them without question
otherwise remember as joe biden said
that radio host
you ain't black the inescapable
conclusion from
all that has been tolerated in liberal
cities these past 10 weeks
if the democrats win the looters will
know
that they have free reign to attack not
just every city and town in the country
but the suburbs as well and that's
exactly
what they'll do and that's the angle